hey guys I'm Ryan right so today you'll
notice I am NOT in my home I am actually
out in San Diego right now I had to
introduce a film at Comic Con and I was
the QA so right now I'm down in SD and
I'm at a friend's place so I'm using
their lovely green couch so today I'm
checking out the trailer the official
call of duty black ops 3 shadow of evil
zombies reveal trailer you know what
this means right more Call of Duty fans
are gonna start getting pissed off and
[ __ ] in anger at other [ __ ] because
it's just not what it used to be I
personally enjoy it your sins serve only
as an invitation an invitation to an
evil beyond your imagination you want to
know what I think I think with the in
punch
I think all this is happening because
we're bad people okay
anyone interested in front row seats to
their own death I know who you are
I have seen each and every one of yours
like romper wicked fights over
you lost know what I am a [ __ ]
samurai killing machine that's what I am
trying to make it happen I don't even
have to get my hands dirty [ __ ] ah it
appears that the shield is quicker than
the eye yes I would like some candy
okay that's like taking candy from a
baby without the baby you're fishing
furious me with path then shoo I will
labor does farmer hi guys oh yeah who
dumped and two dead
oh that's no good what it what is that
what on earth you know it's [ __ ]
weird I don't consider this [ __ ] weird
anymore
I just know this ain't gonna be a fair
fight
you got my wife being she only has two
faces
after
the other airborne wait come on you're
flying [ __ ] that ready for you
Surrender
on a Saturday night pre-order now and
get access to the multiplayer beta well
there there's a lot more than just
zombies in that trailer
I look like actual alien [ __ ] didn't
look like evolved zombies like that some
point it looked kinda like a ghost at
one point I'm not sure it certainly has
a Bioshock feel to it now I know people
are gonna be upset because I I'm pretty
sure that there's gonna be some way you
can use the original four characters
again but I know people really wanted
him to come back they're not but I'm
okay with that you know Jeff Goldblum in
this world I'm pretty sure that's him
and it looked like Ron Perlman sounded
like Ron Perlman so it must be Ron
Perlman you got Hellboy himself inside
of there man that's [ __ ] cool I want
like the old classic zombie feel to it
you know I I hope it doesn't get too
caught up in like its other alien [ __ ]
that's going on I'm sure with like the
demand of wanting the original four back
I'm sure you'll get them in like a bonus
map or something like that because for
me like these new characters look kind
of mysterious they look kind of
interesting to me and I'm okay with it
it seems better than black ops twos new
character take that they had good you
know the sentence I was trying to form
and I say it does have that Bioshock 5 I
mean the 1940s 50s vibe I think it looks
really cool it's gonna be fun to play
that with the kind of Call of Duty
um gameplay that you can do so that's
gonna be a fun environment to be a part
of do ya game looks fun i mean i get
Call of Duty fans I've been getting like
really upset lately with Call of Duty
but I think this game looks like a total
blast I'm definitely gonna check it out
I'll go on a limb and say I'm gonna buy
it but anyway if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine cuz if we get
more followers we can get even more
Chayton wimmer I have watched a lot of
videos by you and subscribe the second I
laugh my ass off love you guys okay
Clayton Wimmer Clayton Wimmer that is a
type of dildo I believe it is also used
as a weapon it's one of those dildos
that it has ammo installed rocket
launcher and also pepper spray yeah in
the rule of three of comedy I should
have put the pepper spray first and then
escalated up to the rocket blaster but
that didn't pan out well but Clayton
Wimmer what I'm trying to say is your
name would be a great dildo if you ever
consider branding your name go with
dildos take care of Clayton